okay so he he's uh pushing but I'm I'm
in his Center so when I uh am going to
uh affect my elbow it'll affect his
elbow but it'll affect his Center okay
so I'm just here you see and you can see
his energy is going that way so to that
I add my weight shift for he's going
around I just keep the arm going around
okay so pay
attention and
[Music]
act a place where uh I'm here and then
this is going to lift his elbow it comes
around and then there's a natural place
where his balance will
be so you don't want to cut
down it'll keep him going
there you kind I can do that same angle
for example but I'm pulling it you see
don't just incrementally boom bringing
them in
[Music]
of course if you wanted to stop this
feet you could stop if you wanted
to we're just working on this
connection okay let's go so it it is
important that he is uh establishing the
initial conflict okay but what happens
sometimes is you're just going here and
you're getting out of the way of him
okay so for example uh I go like this
you see that space there okay I don't
want that space okay um so when I'm
doing it it's
more that I have an adhesion here I'm
not using his fingertips to get it and
then iido culture that he turns okay I I
am open your hand okay I'm working in
there that's where I'm working in
so in here is my I inhesion that's what
I'm using that I
in okay so to demonstrate that more uh
we'll have him pull okay he's pulling
okay and he's ping the whole time and I
should be able to use that
adhes doesn't change the technique okay
so but it will if you're not doing it
okay so I've in this
idea
[Music]
any you can't tell can tell
bull okay all right let's try it for a
confirmation